wenn wir bahnhof verstehen sagen die
manchmal das ist chinesisch für mich
total unverständlich ein buch mit sieben
siegeln
zugleich ist china für viele ein
sehnsuchtsort par excellence der reise
konfuzius der in rätseln spricht die
teezeremonien die entschleunigung
verheißen die chinesische mauer die
größe zeigt welches denken steckt hinter
diesen bildern gibt es eine chinesische
philosophie das frage ich heute kein
marshall professor für philosophie in
taipeh in taiwan herzlich willkommen
dank neuer vor wiese hier zu sagen ja ja
marschall sie waren 19 jahre alt das
beschreiben sie in einem wunderbaren
buch und wollte nicht in einer welt
leben in der es atombomben
biologielehrer ronald reagan warzen und
es gab dann haben sie in berlin gelernt
und sind in die eisenbahn gesessen und
weit weg gefahren am transporter ist
waren ja ja ja das war den ursprünglich
entschluss und ein bisschen ist dieses
buch ein versuch sozusagen mich selbst
zu verstehen also wie kam es eigentlich
dazu wer was für ein mensch war ich
damals mit 17 oder 18 spätpubertäre oder
noch provozierend und irgendwie völlig
verzweifelt ich habe mich sozusagen kein
echtes leben in europa gefunden hatte
diese unendliche sehnsucht nach einem
echten leben und dann kam plötzlich da
diese begeisterung für die alten
schriften also altgriechisch oder maya
oder das chinesisch
ich hab's versucht mir beizubringen als
schlupflöcher so ein bisschen sozusagen
um ein echtes leben zu finden ja hinaus
in die richtige welt und sie haben
darüber ein buch geschrieben sie haben
es schon gesagt und dieses buch ist
voller ironie voller selbstironie sie
beschreiben da auch einen studenten mit
akne der nicht so recht landen kann bei
den frauen der mit sich und der welt
hadert er zieht nach heidelberg späteren
nach paris osaka und schließlich taipeh
und da sind sie nun tatsächlich
professor für philosophie geworden um
das wäre das nicht schon rätselhaft
genug diese ganze reihe hat dieses buch
noch einen sehr rätselhaften titel das
heißt nämlich dreht durch die wand und
werde der du nicht bist
ziemlich rätselhaft genau ja und ich
wollte auch tatsächlich einen
rätselhaften titel also die leserinnen
und leser sollten so sagen dieses gefühl
dass überwältigt science was ich damals
hatte mit als ich zum ersten mal in
china war mit der transsibirischen
eisenbahn nach china mit 22 das sollten
die so ein bisschen nachempfinden können
also ich wollte da nicht einfach
schreiben einführung in die chinesische
philosophie sollte etwas rätselhaft
klingen und tritt durch die wand dass
wir dann sehr schnell klar kommt aus
einem sind klassiker die idee dass man
irgendwie einen perspektivwechsel wirken
muss sich ganz anders sehen mussten die
welt neu sehen muss und werde der du
bist oder werdet ihr die du bist ja
vielleicht heute besser es kommt von
nietzsche ja und dann eben mit diesem
nicht in klammern ironisch wir sind wir
eigentlich vielleicht sind wir ja gar
niemand zu dem wir können werden können
das heißt er täglich sozusagen erfunden
genau ist eine provokation also ich
versuche immer die spiele wie sie gerade
sagten einmal mit dieser ironie des
anderen
ich wollte nicht da sozusagen in
ehrfurcht erstarren vor dem anderen und
dann das das ganz andere
heraufbeschwören sondern irgendwie auch
durch mich selbst was habe ich da
eigentlich gemacht wie in diesen letzten
20 oder 25 jahren wie habe ich
chinesisch gelernt oder wie bin ich
vielleicht selbst fast schon zu
eigentlichen lesen geworden ich wollte
darüber ironisch schreiben und mich
selbst besser verstehen und natürlich
auch vor allem das chinesische denken
vorstellen so weit das geht ja leben ist
ja immer werden irgendwie verändern uns
dauernd und haben trotzdem das gefühl so
eine geschichte zu haben nun glauben sie
sind sie sind mehr ein anderer geworden
wieso ich zum beispiel die eigentlich
immer höher nämlich einer schweiz ohne
frage ja bestimmt also in irgendeiner
weise muss ich das ja ich hab mir
deutschland hätte fast 20 jahren also
ich hab selbst seit etwa 20 jahren lebe
ich nicht mehr in deutschland ich komme
natürlich immer wieder zurück nach
deutschland auch europa und ich lebe in
einer ganz anderen lebenswelt in einem
kontext den viele auch meiner freunde
oder meine oder außer meiner familie
nicht mehr unbedingt verstehen sie
sprachlich nicht mehr nachvollziehen
können und dann aber auch lebenswelt ich
was sind das für menschen eigentlich die
anteile waren oder in shanghai in
hongkong und also ist es einfach ich bin
ja ich bin mir selbst vielleicht auch
nicht mehr ganz durchsichtig glaube dass
jeder von uns ab 40 versteht man selbst
nicht mehr so ganz genau wie man
eigentlich ist glaube ich wenn man
bestimmte entscheidungen die man mit 20
getroffen haben
die bedeutung versteht man vielleicht
erst sehr viel später und auch
vielleicht vielleicht versteht man sie
nicht mehr so ganz
ich denke dass für diese erfahrung als
hoffe ich könnte eigentlich doch viele
menschen nachvollziehen auch wenn sie
nicht wie sie nicht in nicht etwa auf
finde ich jetzt wahnsinnig interessant
als gedacht hat wenn man älter wird
versteht man sich besser vielleicht aber
ist das so
ich bin mir nicht so ganz im sicheren
eurem klaren da und gerade im buddhismus
gibt es natürlich diese grundskepsis
gibt es überhaupt ein beständiges selbst
das da also bin ich damals vor 20 ich
war mal dieser dieser junge mensch
dieser der an sich selbst gelitten hatte
und mit 20 bin ich immer noch derselbe
heute in einer weise natürlich schon ich
verstehe mich noch da und ich irgendwie
ich erkenne mich auch immer wieder in
der der hinterlassenschaft sozusagen
dieses menschen irgendwie bestimmte
charaktereigenschaften eigenschaften
teile ich noch mit ihm aber dann gibt es
eben auch immer wieder das gefühl der
fremdheit und über dieses gefühl der
fremdheit möchte ich heute mit ihnen
sprechen und über diese rätselhaft ich
kite ich habe ganz am anfang auch gesagt
das ist immer beides ist anders als
dieses rätselhafte wenn ich an ostasien
denke und gleichzeitig auch ein
sehnsuchtsort und in ihrem buch nennen
sie ein zitat von cg jung dass mir das
mich sehr berührt hat und zwar hat cd
jungen über das ostasiatische denken
etwas geschrieben und da steht das licht
dieser weisheit leuchtet nur in der
dunkelheit nicht im elektrischen
scheinwerferlicht des europäischen
bewusstseins und willens theater das ist
ein ja ich war das genauso schön wie
sich das wie sie das aber auch gefunden
haben ist also sehr ich muss das
irgendwann mal auf einer bibliotheks
recherche gefunden haben und ich fand
ich das ist mehr sind ja irgendwie mich
das an gesprungen weil es klingt erstmal
sehr orientalis tisch das andere das
irgendwie wir nie durchdringen können
aber dann man darüber nachdenkt dann
trifft er das schon etwas mit der cg
jung der natürlich auch nie wirklich
sinologe war der nicht chinesisch wie
ich gesprochen oder gelesen hat aber er
trifft etwas das die tatsache und ich
fasse das in meinem buch dann so
zusammen dass eben dieses chinesische
denken das klassische chinesische denken
also vielleicht von 500 vor christus bis
leicht 1617 100 ist in die frühe neuzeit
dass dieses denken irgendwie uns
entzogen ist weil eben die lebensform
ganz andere sind
moderne lebensformen sind sehr flexibel
hochflexibel und aussetzen auf autonomie
und auf oft bestimmte werte die den
menschen damals nicht unbedingt vertraut
gewesen ist und an die tatsache ist auch
dass chinesen heute nicht mehr ihre
eigene tradition verstehen also die
situation ist irgendwie etwas entrückt
wobei darüber werden wir noch sprechen
dass ich ja umstritten
gerade in der politik großes bekenntnis
wieder zum sozialismus
aber bei diesem punkt würde ich ganz
gerne kurz mit ihnen bleiben weil sie
jetzt gesagt haben
diese zeit der philosophien ungefähr bis
1600 ist irgendwie so fremd wenn man das
vergleicht mit den lebensformen heute
nun würde ich sagen das ist für uns in
europa genauso also ich lebe jetzt auch
nicht mehr wie aristoteles auf der
akropolis aber gleichzeitig würden wir
doch sagen wir können problemlos über
die freundschaft lesen von aristoteles
oder über die schnelligkeit des lebens
von seneca und das unmittelbar verstehe
ja ja ist das fremde ist natürlich immer
eine sache des vergleichs und und und
sozusagen nicht ich dachte aber damit
rechne ich in meinem buch also man kann
natürlich irgendwie man wie wir finden
irgendwie lesen goethe oder wir lesen
lesen den faust oder wir lesen dann ganz
von berlichingen oder schiller oder
gehören bestimmte opa und und irgendwie
erkennen wir uns sofort in diesen dingen
wieder in diesen kunstwerken und wir
glauben uns dann als europäer und dann
sehen wir so etwas chinesisches zum
beispiel eine kalligraphie oder ein
landschaftsgemälde und und gemälde und
irgendwie verstehen wir das nicht und
wir nehmen das nicht so direkt war es
ist relativ flach sozusagen weil wenn
ich die schrift können wir verstehen
auch nicht die dahinterliegende motive
und auch gerade eine kalligrafie wenn
sie an eine chinesische kalligraphie
gesehen haben vielleicht sehen wir
später noch nicht es ist eine andere
form des kulturellen ausdruck ist und
der uns nicht so sehr an springt eben
wie zum beispiel italienische oper und
und und und da damit sozusagen dann
kommt schnell sehr schnell der vergleich
in china ist eben anders oder china ist
uns irgendwie irgendwie sind wir dann
doch europäer und die europäische
zivilisation ist doch der chinesischen
überlegen
dieser schluss kommt sehr schnell und
dagegen wehre ich mich ein bisschen
genau das aber ich meine jetzt erst
einmal weise gesagt haben diese
chinesische philosophie ist auch für die
heutigen chinesen fragen genau genau
weil eben wenn man sich das anschaut
einmal ist natürlich die tatsache dass
dass diese texte in klassischem
chinesischen verfassung chinesisch
verfasst sind zum beispiel das dressing
also das berühmte diese laute das ist
klassisches chinesisch nicht modernes
chinesisches ist also schon ein bisschen
entrückt und und dann ist die tatsache
eben auch dass die philosophie auch in
china die gegenwart philosophie ist
natürlich viel stärker analytisch und
begrifflich geformt und bedinge sollen
benannt werden und wir haben wir das
eben im klassischen chinesischen texten
so nicht hat dann kommen also wir kommen
viele geschichten viele metaphern und
oft wird als zum beispiel im gang sei
ein klassiker des des taoismus werden
viele geschichten erzählt und parabeln
das würde man eben dagegen was
philosophie auch in china oder in teilen
nicht mehr so machen und das haben wir
ein argument für diese entzogen haid
oder entrücktheit wir sind schon
mittendrin und sie haben gerade den
dauer ismus angesprochen
wir sprechen ja eigentlich von drei
traditionen gleichzeitig wird heute ein
schnellzug eine superschnelle
transsibirische eisenbahn
also wenn du über chinesisches denken
sprechen sprechen über konfuzianismus
tourismus und buddhismus und wir wollen
mal kurz anfangen mit dem konfuzianismus
und ich habe man schon im vorfeld
getroffen eine architektin die in zürich
lebt sich's präsidentin der architekt
und künstler kammer schweiz china und
ich habe sie auch gefragt ob das
chinesische denken und konfuzianismus
für sie auch jeden wie rätselhaft
bleiben
für mich ist die chinesische philosophie
auch rätselhaft sogar schwejk so
verstehen und man versucht seit
generationen immer wieder zu verstehen
wenn man das buch liest
der erste eindruck ist computer sagt
nicht das ist erfreut das ist ein
richtig dass jetzt fast unter er hat
selber wie an art frage gestellt ist das
nicht erfreut ist das nicht wichtig und
es sieht so aus dass ihr selber gar
nicht sicher war
über seine eigene aussage aber im
chinesische mentalität verstehen wir
das so konfus es selber er weiß ganz
genau was jetzt sagen der oder was ich
sagen kann
aber diese frage zeichnen ist für seine
schule für alle nachfolge alle hat frage
im leben ich habe gehört so von
konfuzius apropos dass sie mein leben
funktioniert konfus das gäbe uns die die
möglichkeiten selber auszuüben ihr
unserer realität im praktischen praxis
zu bringen
er hat das war eine sehr schöne eine
sehr schöne einspielung und im grunde
anschaulich dass so ein bisschen was ich
gerade erzählt aber das eben auch für
heutige chinesen und chinesinnen konfus
ist nicht transparent ist also eher
konfus ist eine schillernde figur es
gibt im grunde nicht ein konfuzianismus
und es gibt dutzende konfuzianismus und
genauso gibt es verschiedene konfuzius
gestalten und in jedem jahrhundert haben
die chinesischen dem konfuzius anders
verstanden also dass er einmal erst mal
dieser lehrer und eben auch wie ein
lehrer spricht oft in plattitüden also
der erste satz gleich etwas lernen und
sich dann im erlernten immer wieder üben
ist das nicht zufriedenheit so ein satz
der im grunde gar nichts sagt es ist
eine plastiktüte oder dann werde ich im
griff hat der macht selten fehler
das sind leere sprüche oder oder oder ja
sind aussprüche die diese relativ platt
daherkommen und das ist sozusagen die
die dieser lehrer das darauf beruht die
gesamte ostasiatische kultur dass dieser
lehrer immer recht hat und wegen wie die
schüler werden angehalten diese diese
dieser diese dieser sprüche zu
verinnerlichen und auf ihr eigenes leben
anzuwenden
und dann gibt es gibt eben neben dem
lehrer noch diesen sozusagen ritual und
zuchtmeister nicht dass der oft etwas
autoritär herüber kann darüber kommt
also ein bisschen oberlehrerhaften und
die eigenen schüler hat ja hunderte von
schülern oft auch zusammenstaucht also
seiner charakter schule als er möchte
irgendwie dem dieser diese schüler und
zu eigenen zu besseren menschen machen
und das kann dann auch irgendwie oft
etwas unangenehmes haben und ich ringe
in meinem buch so ein bisschen als ich
ich stoße mich da auch einen
konstruktions also ich möchte nicht von
oben herab über konflikt zu sprechen
sondern wirklich ihn zeigen als einen
lebendigen oder als ein
einen menschen der durchaus auch direkt
auf mit uns sprechen kann und in ein
gespräch kommen kann und neben diesen
beiden ersten konfusion consozial
konfuzius gestalten gibt es noch einen
dritten nicht den ich vielleicht als ein
ironiker bezeichnen würde der also
irgendwie die leute direkt da abholt wo
sie sind in ihren eigenen lebens
probleme und der sich oft doch so ein
bisschen lustig macht über dieses
bedürfnis der eigenen schülerfeste
lehrern zu haben also irgendwie etwas
festes eine antwort zu bekommen auf die
man sich dann immer berufen dass sie
vielleicht gemeint hat er in frage
stellen genau und also konfuzius in
entzieht sich dieses wissens ansprüchen
immer so ein bisschen in diesem punkt
ähnelt ein bisschen sorgten sokratis den
werde ja oft an die seite gestellt aber
da würde ich eben sagen ihr habt nicht
dieses schmeißfliegen haft oder dieses
ruppiger von sokratis also er würde nie
denke ich auch wildfremde menschen auf
der straße ansprechen und damit ihnen
über philosophie diskutieren wollen
dafür war konfuzius sowohl an ständig
irgendwie zu ordentlich und zu sehr an
ritualen interessiert
es gibt ja eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
überliefert klar bücher jetzt von
konfuzius und schreibt ihn einfach
gewisse dinge zu es gibt aber wohl auch
sehr viele zitate die konfuzius
zugeschrieben werden die irgendwann
einfach genau ja genau das da zeigt man
zeigt sich dass wir das ist dieses diese
ohne diese lehre im zentrum der der
tradition die immer irgendwie ausgefüllt
werden muss und es gibt natürlich dann
später konstruktion als der zweiten oder
dritten generation zum beispiel bentzius
wird oft genannt oder auch schön sie
versucht haben diese diese ideen das
konfuzius in systematischer
auszuarbeiten und und da sieht man dann
auch durchaus philosophische traktate
man darf nicht stehenbleiben bei diesem
ersten bild konfuzius als der oberlehrer
oder wie hegel sagt es wäre besser
gewesen ihn gar nicht zu übersetzen wie
so what ist aber man muss sehen es gibt
dann wenig traktate und abhandlungen
über die konfuzianischen ideen und die
dann auch systematisch durchgearbeitet
werden könnte man aber vielleicht auch
sagen so ein eine kernidee des
konfuzianismus ist diese idee des edlen
menschen ja diese idee dass wir
eigentlich charakter stark sein sollen
so gewisse an stanzformen bewahren
zum beispiel respekt gegenüber den armen
gegenüber den eigenen eltern so gewisse
tugenden von innerlichen sollen und
vielleicht was ich interessant finde
auch die überlegung im zentrum steht
nicht so sehr die frage was steht mir zu
wir haben ja heute
im europäischen denkens eine sehr starke
rechts idee ich bin ein individuum mit
rechten ich bin frei geboren und ich
darf für mich sorgen sondern eher
umgekehrt wie kann ich dienen wie bringe
ich mich dazu für andre ward vor genau
das ist sicherlich eine
grundorientierung des klassischen
konfuzianismus die sich bestimmt
durchgehalten hat bis ins 16 oder 17
jahrhundert also darf man nicht
verwechseln mit dem heutigen china aber
traditionell war china in der tat sehr
stark anja juli ein theater einzelne
mensch wurde er wurde an pflichten
ausgerichtet und es gab also ich grade
in der familie natürlich enorme
ansprüche an die anderen die söhne und
die familie weiterzuführen und die
töchter waren sowieso eher ein bisschen
am rande
es gab enorme ansprüche und das ist das
eine es gab natürlich dann auch mal
gegenbewegungen auch also die idee zum
beispiel dass söhne und töchter auch die
eigenen eltern kritisieren dürfen das
gute durch das auch mal artikuliert und
es gab also spreche dann von einem
linken oder rechten konfuzianismus gibt
immer gab immer consozial die stärke an
dieser sozusagen der an der ordnung
interessiert waren also diese familien
ordnung muss auf jeden fall bewahrt
werden und dann gab es auch immer
konfuser die er vielleicht links waren
die sozusagen an die sozialen idealen
interessiert waren zb das ideal der
gleichheit ist sehr wichtig dass eben
alle menschen bildung erhalten müssen
und auch als update 1200 schluss dass
auch frauen ein also nicht nur die
männer auch die frauen sollten eine
bildung erhalten und das ist in vieler
hinsicht wenn man das vergleicht mit
europa ja durchaus modern also im 1213
jahrhundert war europa noch nicht so
weit und da haben die konzeption also
auch durchaus reformatorische oder sogar
revolutionäre züge und dem
konfuzianismus gibt es eben doch diese
ideen die man so ein bisschen
systematischer aufdröseln kann eben
diese tugend idee der edle mensch zum
beispiel
aber wenn wir jetzt weiter gehen zum
dies muss dann wie jetzt für mich ganz
verloren und ich habe auf facebook im
vorfeld auch gefragt was interessiert
euch was interessiert die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer ein chinesischer
philosophie und da war sofort die frage
wir wollen wissen was ist das wunderbare
frage ja in meinem buch beschreibe ich
das also wie ich dann so angefangen habe
mit 22 23
ich hatte etwas chinesisch gelernt und
dann hatte seminare besucht und dann
dieses ringen
wenn man anfängt das dauert im zu lesen
was ist eigentlich das dauert
klassiker
ich hatte gerade den jobs erwähnte
zweiter deutscher klassiker das dating
ist ja das berühmteste buch sagt man
immer in china
also was bei uns die bibel ist ist in
der jetzigen also ist ein klassiker ganz
kurz sind 81 abschnitte über laut laute
ist vielleicht bekannt
sie ist sozusagen der autor der autor
wenn es denn überhaupt gegeben
kann ich gab ihnen zugeschrieben ja es
gab also diesen klassiker dieser text 81
abschnitte und das ist sehr rätselhaft
und irgendwie umkreis der autor dieses
buches das dow und ausdauer wird immer
wieder beschrieben als dunkel ist nicht
zugänglich irgendwie als als als
verworren sagt er vielleicht nicht so
aber sie sehen es ist entzogen es ist es
ist glatt oder das ist übersteigt unsere
vernunft und aber irgendwie versuchte
das irgendwie doch dann einzukreisen und
und wenn man daran definition des dow
sucht dann müsste man so einen klassiker
so soll auf machen und dann nachschauen
aber eine definition in unserem sinne
oder in einem sokratischen sinne gibt es
eben niemals aber muss ich beantworte
das in meinem buch dann so dass eben
diese frage was ist das da letztlich ein
bisschen ein geklammert werden muss es
geht um einen intuitiven einfühlen in
das dow es dauert oft übersetzt als
ordnung oder prinzip oder urgrund das
hat sie verschiedene facetten aber
letztlich kann man diese facetten ja nur
alle zusammen sehen oder man muss sich
in das dow einfühlen er muss es wissen
und das wird dann später an anderen
schulen auch weiterentwickelt das geht
irgendwie darum dass man sobald man das
da weiß dass man dann irgendwie gelingen
in einer gelingenden beziehung zur
wirklichkeit treten kann
sehen sie hier stehe ich jetzt
chinesisch weil ich weil ich eben wie
denke ist also praktisch man muss sich
einüben ja dann ist aber für mich
ziemlich weit weg vom philosophie ist
dass da irgendwas wie meditieren sowas
wie im buddhismus sich ins nirwana jeden
die begeben wollen sich ins nichts
verschenken was die auseinandersetzung
darüber ob die frage also über über die
frage ob buddhismus und taoismus für das
philosophie sind könnte vielleicht
später noch mal sprechen aber sozusagen
der dow ist muss hat einige
übereinstimmung mit dem buddhismus und
gerade in morgen b
der hauptfigur meines buches eine
analyse von morgen mache ich das ja ein
bisschen klar sie vielleicht haben sie
ganz cool der bank ist im dritten
jahrhundert nach christus dieses jahr
unglaubliche genie das nur 23 jahre lang
gelebt hat und doch die drei wichtigsten
bücher der chinesischen zivilisation
kommentiert hat also das dauert an die
gespräche des konfuzius deshalb werde
der amerikanischen erwähnt und das buch
der wandlungen da sind sich die drei
classic situation und er im alter von 15
oder 16 wie ich als ganz junger mann
muss er sich das erarbeitet haben und
dann das aufgeschrieben und ist dann mit
23 jahren an einer krankheit verstorben
und und dieser lebt im dritten
jahrhundert nach christus also etwa zur
zeit des römischen weltreichs und in
einer ganz eigenartigen zeit wo china im
bürgerkrieg vertrieb bürgerkrieg
versunken war und dass so viele zusagen
gewissheiten sind zusammengebrochen und
die die menschen waren auf der suche und
hatten so seien mit der physisches
bedürfnis dann gab es plötzlich viele
junge menschen die dann drogen genommen
haben das bestreite ich in meinem buch
also diese diese hush hush rebellen
sozusagen wieso ist ja wieder 68 jahre
lebten dann da in diesen chinesischen
städten und dann sagen sie natürlich
super kombi mittendrin der
wahrscheinlich auch mit von diesen
drogen genommen hat und dann aber
gleichzeitig eben ganz relativ nüchtern
oder rational diese drei texte
kommentiert hat und dass das ja bis
heute glaube ich dass waren die zusagen
der ground zero der chinesischen kultur
ist zugegen
also dieser waren wie der kreis auch um
dieses nichts ganz viele meiner texte
befassen sich mit dem nichts kann man ja
polemisch sagen wie kann man sich mit
nichts befassen
vielleicht ja eben nichts eine chance
frage also dass nichts im dow ist muss
man sich das anschaut dann ist es ein
leerer begriff also sagen es kommt nur
frei oder 2 2 wahrscheinlich ja also es
ist lea es wird nicht direkt ausgeführt
einmal gibt es eine kosmologische
erzählung beiwagen wie das irgendwie das
gesamte weltall aus dem nichts
entstanden ist das kann man noch mal ich
verstehe sowieso wieder big bang ist da
gab es mal dass nichts und irgendwie
alles nichts war schöpferisch tätig hat
hat das gesamte weltall und die 10.000
dinge hervorgebracht ist das eine und
dann gab es eben diese andere gibt es
bei morgen diese andere erzählung das
dass das nicht irgendwie in unserem
alltag direkt vorhanden ist und das war
also soll ich vielleicht auch durch
meditation bestimmte ja sozusagen das
asketische praktiken sich dem nichts
nähern kann also dass man indem man die
eigene ego zentralität abbaut oder der
deutsche philosoph ernst tugendhat hat
ein sehr schönes buch zu überschrieben
das eben das dauer nicht als ein
metaphysischer begriff letztlich
verstanden werden darf sondern
lebenspraktisch also dass da oder das
nichts sind bestimmte
orientierungspunkte und wir indem wir
und sozusagen ausrichten auf das nichts
und unsere eigenen begierden reduzieren
so heißt es im dortigen werden wir
öffnen wir uns im grunde für die
lebendige gegenwart
wir müssen das eigene ich ein bisschen
ein klammern
dieser gedanke ist im grunde schon sehr
nah am buddhismus um dieser gedanke auch
jetzt im modernen china unter ihren
studierenden ist das wird auch
praktiziert
es gibt ja immer schon in eine
interessierte in chinesischsprachigen
gesellschaften einen populären dauert
muss er einen sogenannten religiösen
tourismus und der ist in china vorhanden
oder kommt jetzt wieder aber gerade in
hongkong und taiwan ist extrem
verbreitet also ich wahrscheinlich wenn
man meine unfall in meinungsumfragen
dann würde man sehen dass wahrscheinlich
die hälfte der taiwanischen menschen
leisten sind also also es gibt einen
tempel wo man reingeht und man es gibt
bestimmte gottheiten und die dann das
personal personifizieren und denen man
sich irgendwie nah dass der religiöse
tourismus dann gibt es eben auch den
philosophischen da ist muss und wann be
gehört er zuletzt war natürlich
übereinstimmungen und das ist ja
interessant weil sie vorher noch gesagt
haben
wir können darüber diskutieren ob dieses
und tourismus eigentlich religionen sind
und ein kriterium könnte sein gibt es
eigentlich gottheiten die man
die gibt es ja zb konfuzianismus
klarerweise nicht
es gibt keine gott heiligen geist so
ahnen geister ja aber man betet nicht
sein gott dem konfuzianismus also es
kann also diese idee dass da ein
allmächtiger allwissender gott sei der
uns irgendwie alles der alles weiß was
wir tun und er uns irgendwie auch der
zukunft kennt wie wir das im christentum
haben die gab es natürlich nicht das
gibt es aber auch nicht im buddhismus
und überhaupt ich habe dann gibt's wm
dauert muss also in diesem religiösen
tourismus nicht gerade beschrieben haben
gibt es halt lokal gottheiten muss zum
beispiel wir haben also mit oder werden
sogar bäume an gebeten oder bestimmte
angebetet bestimmten menschen die sich
später in gottheiten verwandelt haben
das aber er dann dieser saison was ich
gerade was ich gerade den religiösen
tourismus genannt haben es gehört er
dazu hören jetzt haben sie vorhin auch
das buch der wandlungen erwähnt ein ganz
wichtiges buch eben neben diesem ding
und dieser anderen konfession ist ischen
inschriften und in diesem buch geht es
auch um die frage wie verändert sich
eigentlich alles was kommt woher wie
hängt das alles zusammen und da gibt's
ein prinzip dass sie nun die young
prinzip und das fand ich zb als kind
ganz toll und als jugendliche das ist
mein alter geldbeutel uralte weile den
ich auch nicht mehr benutzen aber das
ist mir wieder eingefallen weil ich in
meiner jugend haben wir dieses teilchen
unfassbar toll und für uns war das das
zeichen männlich und weiblich irgendwie
neigen wir sind es hier auch noch einmal
in schwarz weiß
aber das ist ein sehr viel umfassenderes
zeichen eigentlich ihn und jahren wobei
das zeichen das symbol selbst stammt ja
erst aus dem elften jahrhundert
aber die idee ist viel älter also in und
gerade also ein buch der wandlungen ist
es ganz zentral und im tessin sind also
wir kräfte also ich spreche man von wir
kräften und sie haben gerade das
männliche und weibliche angesprochen ist
natürlich so sind ist es abstrakte also
sein aktives prinzip und ein passives
prinzip das ist ein helles war im
prinzip der helle und ein prinzip der
dunkelheit so wird das in allen
klassischen texten beschrieben und und
es sind keine es ist also in china
kannte kein atom is muss oder man nahm
es gebe also energieströme oder wirkt
kräfte und in & young hat man dann
herangezogen um das zu beschreiben also
zum beispiel im frühjahr wenn sozusagen
alles blüht und gedeiht dann kommt das
young und im herbst er denn das in so zu
sagen es gibt da eine in der türkei eine
zyklische bewegung also was sie panta
rhei bei heraklit alles lief ja
vielleicht ja wenn manchmal wird es
damit verglichen das also diesen und
jagen ist natürlich nicht erfahrung
sozusagen wissenschaftliche nachweis man
alles und bestimmte kategorien die man
in sehr vielen dieser frühen
chinesischen texte findet und die für
diese menschen damals sind gemacht
für sie spielt das eine ganz große rolle
sie haben ja auch gesagt sie wären
bereit hier noch so andere hin und
jahrgangs aufzuzeigen und da geht es
jetzt um hexa gramm jetzt bin ich sehr
gespannt sei ehrlich gesagt habe ich das
im buch nicht alles ganz verstanden
jetzt würde hoffentlich nicht esoterisch
ja also das ist die idee dass
chinesische philosophie esoterisch sei
sollten wir zu seite sollten wir sollten
wir zurückweisen
also dass zum beispiel das ist das erste
das erste hexagon nummer eins das
schöpferische da sehen wir von unten
123456 sechs plätze und jeder auf jedem
platz kann entweder eine young linie
also hektar kommen eine zeichnung mit
sex her genau einer linie zu sagen
durchgezogene linie vertritt das young
und eine unterbrochene linie vertritt
das in und man kann sich dann überlegen
also wenn es sechs plätze gibt und zwei
möglichkeiten gibt es insgesamt 64
möglichkeiten und so bringt die
angeordneten gibt es 64 hektar gamma und
leibnitz war zum beispiel fasziniert von
dieser idee also das kommt
wahrscheinlich aus der wahrsagerei sind
also 1000 vor christus oder so ist das
buch der wandlungen verfasst worden
und das hat seinen ursprung in der
wahrsagerei aber es wurde dann später in
der chinesischen kultur immer mehr ja
mit abstrahiert es wurde immer
abstrakter gefasst und wurde immer
philosoph stärker philosophisch
aufgeladen
so dass man eben da nimmt dieses extra
gramm das schöpferische nummer eins das
man nur ja nur jan und man sich den
rhein das reine young die reine energie
ist mal eben dann angenommen hat in der
natur könne man dieses jahr direkt sehen
dieses extra gramm und die leute haben
dann zum beispiel wird zum beispiel eben
diese die idee des frühlings was ich
gerade gesehen hast nur ja ja ja und
dann gibt es eben dass sechs gramm
nummer zwei zum beispiel des rheines in
das sieht man allein verbringen
genau also diese sechs mal und dann ja
dann gibt es alle alle möglichen anderen
ex agrar wir vielleicht noch ein
weiteres
und um das zu veranschaulichen
also dass dieses dass es geht die
stockung und warum das heißt dass die
stockung vielleicht kann man das so
erklären dass unten dreimal in liegt
also von unten nach oben muss man das
lesen und oben ist sozusagen dieses
innen blockiert von diesen drei jahren
linien und ist also eine dynamik ein
dynamischer prozess der an gewährt den
sind also die alten chinesischen
philosophen zu folgen jeder zeit
stattfindet das heißt unsere ganze welt
könnte beschrieben werden das werden und
vergehen das männliche und das weibliche
das helium etwas dunklere 64 hexa kommen
natürlich konstellation dass bestimmte
konstellation die man im leben antritt
und hab das auch eine auswirkung auf
mein eigenes leben also gibt es phasen
da bin ich jenen schaffen da bin ich ja
dann auch nicht ja ja keiner also zum
beispiel wie ich gerade gesagt hat das
buch der wandlung hat seinen ursprung in
der bäckerei und bis heute findet man
wahrsager in taiwan also in taipeh auf
den straßen oder in hongkong die sowas
dann auch der in einem auslegen können
also entweder an zum beispiel mit dem
hilfe des mülls orakels also die münze
hat zwei seiten einmal in ein mann wirft
die münze kann man also sozusagen sich
mit mit hilfe von sechs würfen einen
extra gramm zusammenbauen und der
wahrsager und man geht zum wahrsager und
stellt eine frage also wie es jetzt die
situation in der ich mich gerade befinde
ich möchte zum beispiel ein haus kaufen
und ich möchte eine familie gründen der
wahrsager betätigt dann dieses orakel
und legt einem dann eine extra gamma und
das kann man dann weiter interpretieren
und zu sagen auf das eigene leben
anwenden
diese wahrsagerei also ich hab dann zb
beispiel dürfte der für mich und es gibt
dann sollte ich daraus ablesen ob ich
das haus jetzt kaufen soll oder nicht es
gibt eben in diesem buch der wanderung
nicht nur diese extra grammer sondern es
gibt dazu sprüche und diese sprüche kann
man deuten und das ist auch so zu sagen
natürlich ich gebe das gern zu ist ein
etwas was uns dass sich uns entzieht
weil wir natürlich damit nicht
aufgewachsen sind auch die heutigen
chinesen die wenigsten chinesen kennen
das noch aber in der traditionellen
gelehrten kultur chinas war das standard
war also jeder gelehrte oder jena jeder
mensch dass ich irgendwie als
intellektueller verstanden hat der kante
dieser 64 extra gramm und ist eben damit
so vorgegangen
das ist man kann sich sehr abstrakt
zusammen so ein bisschen vielleicht wie
bei platon man sich überlegt plant die
ideen lehre ist ja auch relativ weit
abgehoben von unserer lebenswelt gegen
oder weise gab es der spekulation oder
gibt die peter korea also ist es ist
natürlich nicht mehr leben nicht mehr
uns heute nicht mehr so sehr nah aber es
ist teil der chinesischen kultur und ich
würde sagen auch teil einer einer
globalen philosophie nicht interessiert
natürlich als philosophin und sie
genauso immer auch der zusammenhang
zwischen sprache und denken und wenn ich
ihm zu hören
dieses buch lese habe ich auch den
eindruck sie haben nicht nur eine neue
sprache gelernt und sich in neue
denkformen ein gedacht sondern
wahrscheinlich habt dass ihr eigenes
denken auch wieder verändert und das
betrifft ja auch die schrift sie haben
ein buch mitgebracht wird beginnt ja
schon damit dass wenn man dieses buch
auspackt dass man das verkehrt um
erhalten muss das genau es ist sozusagen
alles verkehrt
das heißt ein ein exemplar ich wollte
das einmal mitbringen als ein beispiel
also eine ein buch in traditioneller
faden bindung dass dieses heute sehen
die bücher natürlich nicht mehr so aus
aber bis vor etwa 100 jahren gab es
solche bücher und das ist eine
reproduktion und das buch muss man dann
tatsächlich so aufmachen und es ist also
jetzt sie sehen jetzt zu sehen ist sehen
ist richtig froh blättern genau und dann
also von rechts nach links und von oben
nach unten also jetzt stets auf den kopf
nicht lesen aber grundsätzlich könnte
ich das lesen sie müssten so sozusagen
mit dem finger dann oft die einzelnen
zeichen hervorheben und sie sehen es
gibt keinerlei punkte
die punkte wurden dann von den lesern
selbst eingetragen
das ist alles sehr abstrakt für uns weil
wir die zusammenhänge nicht kennen und
da komme ich da wieder auf der sondern
den anfangs meiner unseres gesprächs
zurück
das ist derart darin zeigt sich die
fremdheit des ganzen gegenstände und
fremdheit sollte man aber eben nicht
verabsolutieren
es soll ist die weil diese kultur uns
fremd ist heißt das nicht dass nur
chinesen über chinesische kultur
schreiben können auch wir als europäer
können uns da ein rational so sei ein
zugang der arbeiten zu dieser kultur
das heißt ja nicht dass ich jetzt alles
glaube das ist ein bestimmtes allein
rowohlt wie oder ein glaubenssystem
sozusagen eine system das auch durchaus
rational mit argumenten begründet werden
kann
gibt es einen bestimmten begriff oder
eine idee die sie nur auf chinesisch
ausdrücken können und was sie denken da
hab ich wirklich was eine neue idee
gelernt oder eine neue sichtweise
alleine dadurch dass sich diese sprache
jetzt beherrsche
na ja sehr gute frage also es gibt es
einzelne wörter die man natürlich im
chinesischen anders verwendet oder die
kontexte sind an dass die schattierung
sind anders man grundsätzlich glaube ich
natürlich dass man jeden chinesischen
text in eine westliche sprache
übersetzen kann und auch umgekehrt also
ich bin nicht der meinung dass die
sprache nicht übersetzbar sind man kann
es übersetzen aber in dem prozess der
übersetzung gehen bestimmte semantische
gehalte verloren zum beispiel die idee
der wiedergeburt sie uns natürlich
irgendwie auch alle allen präsent ist
also wir lernen dass in der schule was
heißt wiedergeburt und wenn man dann
sozusagen in diesem chinesischen
kontexten das wort zu verstehen versucht
dann merkt man dass es sind andere
pragmatische zusammenhänge also wir
würden wahrscheinlich auf dem deutschen
sehr dekorativ sagen ich glaube an die
wiedergeburt wenn man gut ist ist
ich bin kein buddhist also ich würde das
nicht unterschreiben war eine
buddhistische würde das vielleicht so
sagen chinesisch würde man das nie so
sagen ich glaube dass und ich glaube an
einen gott ich glaube an eine
wiedergeburt
das viel stärker pragmatisch zu sagen
gegründet das kommt bestimmt konnte ist
ein hintergrund überzeugungen die eben
noch bei sehr vielen menschen präsent
sind
aber es ist keine frage dass glauben
dass man muss das nicht irgendwie vier
monate ist muss als ein individuum
bestätigen jetzt haben wir schon öfters
darüber gesprochen lässt sich eigentlich
chinesische philosophie übersetzen bis
hin zur frage ist das überhaupt
philosophie und darüber halte ich auch
gerne mit ihnen sprechen weil das
nämlich auch ein anliegen ist von ihnen
sie haben dazu auch mal einen aufsatz
geschrieben im merkur das war sozusagen
auch der aufsatz bei denen ich auf sie
aufmerksam wurde da nicht das so
interessiert hat und zwar haben sie da
einen verwiesen auf einen aufsatz von
brian von norden und chipperfield die
haben 2016 investoren eine zeitschrift
sich beklagt und haben gesagt die
philosophie ist komplett eurozentrische
eurozentristisch an unseren lehrstühlen
in europa in den usa in australien wird
eigentlich nur westliche eurozentrische
philosophie unterrichtet ostasiatische
philosophie afrikanische philosophie die
hartmann zur ethnologie oder zur
sinologie oder zur afrikanistik
geschlagen aber sicher nicht zu den
philosophischen lehrstühlen und das
unterschreiben sie ein stück weit auch
die können richtig also es ist natürlich
ein amerikanischer kontext der in europa
eine andere ist also es gibt eben in
einem vereinigten staaten den
multikulturalismus und das wird sehr
stark auf politisch aufgeladen und es in
diesem zusammenhang ist also sondern
diese anschuldigung des rassismus
gefallen
bryan verloren etwas gebracht hat das
eben philosophen die sich nicht öffnen
für nicht westlichen philosophie
letztlich rassistisch motiviert sein und
so weit würde ich nicht gehen also ich
habe davis also eine eine etwas
moderater moderatere position und ich
denke dass die die lehrstühle der
philosophie früher oder später sicher in
der tat öffnen müssen für denkt
traditionen wie die arabische
philosophie oder wie die indische
philosophie die chinesische japanische
philosophie in gewisser weise tun sie
das ja auch schon weil eben diese
texte seit langem über jahrhunderte auf
uns gewirkt haben also diese texte sind
sind nicht etwas anderes was sind
sozusagen gegenüber steht sondern sie
sind in unsere eigene tradition schon
längst angekommen also man sich anschaut
werden wie leibniz die nicht gerade
erwähnt habe dass ich sehr früh schon
interessiert hat für das buch der
wandlungen oder später eben schopenhauer
oder heidegger oder sogar rusal der
früher usa der sich begeistert zu den
buddhismus da sieht man dass man auch
die eigene tradition letztlich nur
angemessen verstehen kann wenn man sich
diese möglichkeit öffne das sozusagen
andere denkt systeme da gibt und andere
argumente die wir so nicht haben in
unserer eigenen tradition dass ein akku
1 1 zu sein erst theoretisches argument
aber man muss sich sozusagen um also
diese diese man kann diese diese linie
nicht a priori ziehen also das ist
philosophie dass es nicht philosophie
weil der philosophie begriff bei uns
selbst ja auch umstritten ist und dann
das ist richtig und trotzdem gibt es ja
so die frage habe ich mich dann auch
gefragt der vorbereitung was ist
eigentlich philosophie für mich und ich
würde schon sagen in meinem wieder so
viel studium in dem was ich betreibe
wenn ich philosophie betreibe geht
natürlich unseren anspruch klarheit zu
schaffen ich möchte gerne mit begriffen
vorankommen ich nutze das argument und
warte auf ein besseres argument um meine
meinung zu revidieren
und wenn ich jetzt texte lese von
konfuzius dann finde ich kein argument
das habe ich zugegeben der konfuzius
selbst ist eben eine einer eine
schillernde gestalt der nicht
systematisch eine position entwickelt
aber es gibt eben später konfuzianische
texter die leider zu wenig gelesen
werden in europa wie demenz und in jeans
oder auch zu mich hier im zwölften
jahrhundert wo eben dann doch
tatsächlich argumente gebracht werden
das rätselhaft
ich versuche das selbe könnte man über
die indische firma visa und indische
philosophie ist vielleicht hat ein sehr
gutes beispiel weil sozusagen
systematisch argument über die zeit über
subjektivität was heißt eigentlich
bewusst sein
die gab es da die sind da sehr früh
ausformuliert worden und so jemand viel
engagement den ich auch in meinem buch
erwähnen der im grunde wichtiger noch
ist
der historische wurde der oft als der
zweite bruder geführt er hat eine ganz
philosophisch hochinteressante version
des buddhismus entwickelt und diese
version wo ist hat sich sehr früh dann
ist chinesische gesetzt worden und hat
in china gewirkt so dass man im grunde
auch nicht von der chinesischen
philosophie sprechen sollte sondern eher
von einem so etwas von einer hybriden
ostasiatischen philosophie die tradition
sind im gespräch gewesen
ich mache einen vorschlag wir werden
noch eine liste machen mit texten die
vielleicht auf englisch oder deutsch
erhältlich sind chinesische philosophie
bei dem man wirklich was versteht nicht
wie konfuzius und dann stellen wir auf
facebook okay dann kann man sich dann an
diesen einlesen
ich finde trotzdem interessant sie haben
ein paar philosophen jetzt erwähnt die
sich tatsächlich schon auf chinesisch
wieder sowie bezogen haben also
schopenhauer ist ein sehr gutes beispiel
sie haben ernst tugendhat erwähnen
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich schon
auch so eine engführung in der
philosophie würde man sagen die
analytische philosophie die immer
wichtiger wird auch in deutschland in
der schweiz wird sehr viel analytische
philosophie angelsächsisch geprägte für
sophie betrieben und was ich zum
beispiel schätzen dieser philosophie ist
tatsächlich eben diese klarheit dieses
gefühl von man kann sich argumentativ
austauschen und sie würden also sagen
das ist ein absolutes missverständnis
und ein vorurteil das ostasiatische
philosophie weniger klar ist genau einen
meter genau
also ich schätze die kleinen auch sehr
also ich bin in einem philosophie
department ich wenn ich zum beispiel
meine studierenden über den magath so
nah sprecher diesen wichtigen buddhisten
nämlich gerade genannt habe da muss ich
auch mit argumenten argumenten kommen
also die die studenten durch die
studierenden stellen mir ganz ähnliche
fragen wie wie sie eben auch in einem
deutschen philosophie die paten gestellt
würden und diese argumente gibt es aber
auch deswegen ist die und auch die
saison diese idee das buddhistische
denker nicht nach klarheit gestrebt
hätten ist wahrscheinlich ein
missverständnis in der tat weil es das
gab und das kommt natürlich muss hat
sich auch darüber sprechen was heißt
eigentlich klarheit heißt das nun
begriffliche klarheit glaubt man daran
dass man begriffe immer weiter aus
definieren kann und sozusagen ein
begriffs netz errichten kann das dann
eine frau unsere fragen lösen kann
oder gibt es nicht auch für andere
momente zum beispiel therapeutische
aspekte in der philosophie die wir auch
berücksichtigen soll
ja und interessant ist ja das ist
wiederum in der hand von europa die
kritik gibt an der
politischen philosophie dass sie zu sehr
auf die argumentativen schluck trümmer
auf begriffsklärung raus ist und dass
gewisse dinge der philosophie vielleicht
auch volle noch nicht gewiss attack sich
dann der späte schelling zb der lässt
sich natürlich überhaupt nicht erfassen
wenn man aus der analytischen
philosophie
ich denke michael hampe spricht dass er
schon von einer pendelbewegung in der
europäischen philosophie geschichte ist
gab immer die einerseits auf der einen
seite diese sollen diese idee dass man
begrifflich probleme klären könne dann
oft unsere seien systematisch auch ein
ausformulieren ein system entwickeln
können
auf der andern seite gab es eben eben
über diese idee dass philosophie auch
irgendwie lebensweltlich relevant sein
müsste und das therapeutisch genau um
diese beiden elemente also kannst du
hier findet man in der europäischen
philosophie geschichte und deswegen ist
da kein absoluter gegensatz zu sagen zu
konstruieren zur ostasiatischen
philosophie wie schaut denn ein
curriculum aus sein ein lehrplan bei
ihnen in taipeh
die studierenden in china wenn auch so
dass sie gerne auch jetzt nietzsche und
kommt lesen
taipeh ist natürlich zu sagen die
republik china also es ist nicht direkt
teil von china da gibt es viele
politische diskussionen darum aber nicht
sozusagen als 1 1 eine eine liberale
liberal demokratisches land das in dem
man aber diese chinesischen tradition
doch noch an trifft im leben und und so
gibt es eben es ist erstaunlich und
unter den fliesen philosophie
départements in thailand gibt es immer
lehrstühle für europäische philosophie
geschichte und dann lehrstühle für
chinesische philosophie geschichte oder
auch dann lehrstühle für den buddhismus
ich habe einen ersten teaser die
philosophiegeschichte natürlich auch
interessant
ein deutscher ein deutscher
wissenschaftler ja und meine
studierenden die studieren alles möglich
also david davidson klein kant hegel
sind natürlich auch gängige nahmen sie
die die leute auch anziehen oder sagten
eben die russen die phänologie genießt
einen sehr guten ruf
und dann gibt es aber eben auch immer so
sagen leute die sich stärker für den dow
ist muss interessieren oder für den
konfuzianismus es gibt da keinen
sozusagen absoluten gegensatz die leute
sprechen alle miteinander und das ist im
grunde das schöne an meiner situation
beruflichen situationen taiwan dass man
sehr tolerant ist gegenüber diesen
anderen tradition
ich habe mir überlegt ist nicht dieses
sprechen darüber was ist jetzt
philosophie und was nicht wie sollten
wir die lehrstühle benennen immer auch
sehr stark geprägt von den vorurteilen
und dass ich ja sowieso etwas
interessantes wenn man an diesen
interkulturellen austausch denkt
schaffen wir es überhaupt aus unserem
blickwinkel heraus zu steigen und
vorurteilsfrei zu blicken
wahrscheinlich nie und ich hab dann auch
mal angefragt welche vorurteile waren es
eigentlich die ihr entgegengebracht
worden sind als sie in der schweiz ankam
ich möchte das ganz kurz zusammen
anschauen am anfang in der schweiz wie
vor 14 jahren in der schweiz gekommen
bin wurde ich dann also zimmersuche für
mich und dann habe ich durch einen
kollegen kennen gelernt dass jemand ein
auto damit ein zimmer in ihrem eigenen
haus vermieten
dann bist du dazu die damen gegangen und
dann aus sie die tür aufgemacht hat sie
sind ganz heiliger und damen und mit dem
putter hunde im arme dann hat er ja
vorkommen sie hat sie mich gefragt habe
ich gesagt ich komme aus china und hat
sie und geschaut und mich gefragt
es sind sie hund ein gängiges vorurteil
dass hunde essen ja also ich chinesen
essen in der tat hunde also ich bin in
meinem buch beschreibe ich das einmal
wie ich selbst einmal runde fleisch
gegessen habe mehr oder weniger
unwissentlich in china und ich bin dann
hat mir später vorwürfe gemacht das
hätte ich nicht tun sollen aber aber
hundefleisch wird in der tat oft noch
gegessen bevor nicht gelesen haben ja
nicht überall ist natürlich auch das
kann leicht ein klischee werden wenn man
das so sagt aber es ist ja teil der
lebenswirklichkeit in und gleichzeitig
war das jetzt für mulan zb ein vorurteil
etwas was sie irritiert habe dass man
sie das fragt deshalb da das ist mein
buch ist ein plädoyer für die genaue
beobachtung von möglichkeiten also
wir sprechen immer sehr schnell über
china oder sowieso über außer
europäische länder sprechen wir und
kulturen sprechen wir sehr schnell weil
wir keine zeit haben und weil wir
natürlich irgendwie ja unser irgendwie
herüberkommen wollen etwas
herüberbringen aber ich plädiere dafür
dass man sich die zeit nehmen sollte das
andere wirklich zu verstehen und zu
erleben und es gerade so ein beispiel
mit dem unter fleisches sehr gut weil
das ich will nicht dass es ganz falsch
ist aber es ist eben doch sehr
vereinfachend wenn man plötzlich sagt
chinesen essen hundefleisch es ist ein
gibt es vorurteile die ihnen gegenüber
gebracht worden das deutsche ja eine
sehr gute frage als deutscher in einer
chinesischsprachigen gesellschaft
einerseits natürlich immer für sehr
rational gehalten also aus deutschland
kommt im grunde alles sozusagen oder
sehr vieles was für die moderne wichtig
gewesen ist also von der
naturwissenschaften die chemie die
biologie und die juristerei die
jurisprudenz und dann die philosophie
das wird natürlich auch in taiwan ist
und diese idee ist immer dass ein
deutscher in irgendeiner weise an diesem
erbe teil hat und dass auch die
denkweise eines deutschen dann sehr
rational sein müsste dass das eine ja
und dann gibt es vielleicht ja ich bin
ja als ein weißer mann als als weiser
mann werde ich wahrgenommen und in
thailand gibt es vorurteile gegen
ausländer wie überall also zum beispiel
ist die idee dass ausländer oft ja
trinken und sich irgendwie nicht zu
benehmen wissen nicht so gesetzt sind
oder so selbst sich selbst im griff
haben die chinesen und dann passt sich
zum beispiel darauf dass also bestimmte
bewegungen vielleicht vermeiden sollte
oder so dass man ja obama hat das mal
sehr schön gesagt wir als farbiger
menschen usa also wir in der
öffentlichkeit eben sich langsamer
bewegen müsste um nicht mit bestimmten
menschen ja assoziiert zu werden und
dann muss ich oft denken im alltag also
dass man im alltag einfach ja bestimmt
so sah etwas konservativer auftreten
muss als ich in deutschland auftreten
würde das ist vielleicht so ein ding ja
sprechen wir noch über das moderne china
und das moderne taiwan etwas ja
interessant ist dass der regierungschef
von china der jetzige also jean ping der
legt großen wert auf den konfuzianismus
es gibt ein richtiges konfuzianismus
revival es gibt das so genannte soft
power strategie rund um den erdball
konfuzianismus institute die entstehen
das ist ein stück weit natürlich einfach
so eine macht
demonstrationen sind sehr stark
kontrolliert von china aus und trotzdem
kann man sagen der konfuzianismus wird
wieder hervorgekramt gepflegt ist das
ein ehrliches interesse daran
ja ja das ist eine sehr komplizierte
frage also wenn sie sagen ehrlich dann
scheinen sie abzuheben auf seine
intentionen also in peking ist jan
sozusagen aufrichtig und dann da da dam
esse ich mir kein urteil zu das hat sich
in weiterhin sicht auch einen gegenstand
der empirischen sozialforschung und ich
bin da habt ihr bestimmte meinung aber
ich denke ich bin offen für andere
meinung aber grundsätzlich auch in
meinem buch vertritt die these denke ich
nicht dass das heutige china
konfuzianische ist oder in einer weise
wie die konfuzianische werden könne war
einfach zuviel weggefallen ist also über
die letzten jahrhundert jahre ist zum
beispiel das konfuzianische
prüfungswesen das war mir sehr wichtig
weggebrochen und auch der kult um den
himmel und bestimmte religiöse elemente
ist noch längst weggebrochen das eben in
der traditionellen chinesischen
gesellschaft war es das sehr wichtig
klassische texte zu verinnerlichen und
dann in prüfungen also in den beamten
prüfungen zu sagen zu reproduzieren und
das war teil so sagen dass soziale kitt
der soziale kitt mit denen mit dem ich
in diesen sprachen gesellschaften durch
die jahrhunderte das verstehst du
verstehen nicht also wenn man jetzt eine
stelle möchte beim start genauestens
rezitieren es gab dann einen bestimmten
kann und die man auswendig lernen musste
im zb im zwölften jahrhundert in der
gymnastik ich habe ja diesen text so
sagen gerade in die kamera gehalten ist
ein ritual handbuch und diese zum
beispiel so ein text musste man mehr
oder weniger verinnerlicht haben und
dann in einer prüfung wieder geben er
musste fragen zu diesem text beantworten
das war so ein 1 1 ein relativ
rationales element eigentlich zum
beispiel franzosen im 18 oder 19 jahren
haben sich inspirieren lassen als sie
ihre eigene system der bankenprüfung
aufgebaut haben von den chinesen zwar
ein relatives modernes element der ja
der der der elitenbildung und da
spielten zusammen kommissarische text
eine sehr große rolle wenn man sich
anschaut wie heute eliten gebildet
werden in china
dann findet man das eben nicht mehr alle
der marxismus und wischte oder der
leninismus der maoismus sind sozusagen
der der content social content oder der
audio logical der ideologische gehalt
dieses gesamten staates konfuzianische
ideen werden ab und zu mal präsentiert
in der öffentlichkeit also shipping in
seinen reden
beruft sich gern mal auf konfuzius und
es gibt die konfuzius institute die sie
erwähnt haben
aber ich habe immer den verdacht dass es
eine fassade ist ja und in der
lebenswirklichkeit der menschen
es gibt bestimmte elemente die man
vielleicht zu verstehen kann also das
bedürfnis nach harmonie so dass die
leute zum beispiel einem runden tisch
sitzen was wir oft sehr merkwürdig
finden wir sitzen am eckigen tisches
heute ja auch aber ich in diesen sitzen
immer irgendwie an runden tischen woher
kommt das so dass man zusammen ist dass
nicht jeder selbst für sich bestellt
sondern dass man gerichte zusammen was
man sieht und sie teilte das wirkt für
uns eigentümlich und das wird dann so
oft verstanden als ausdruck der
traditionellen chinesischen kultur unter
mag was dran sein und im bildungssystem
in der sozialen realität sind chinesen
ganz knallhart in der durchsetzung ihrer
eigenen interessen wenn man sich
anschaut wie chinesen heutzutage in
china ihre interessen durchsetzen oder
außerhalb von china das ist knallharte
macht logik und zu sein dieses was sie
gerade angesprochen hatten diese dieses
ideal des des edlen der chinese der sich
sozusagen zurückhält und auf harmonie
bedacht ist und tritt die rituale
einhält das findet man da nicht warum
ist es denn für mich so wenn ich kontakt
habe zu chinesen dass ich trotzdem den
eindruck habe von einer unglaublichen
höflichkeit auch distanziertheit aber so
dieser edelmut das passt für mich sehr
gut darf begriff um so wissenschafts
aufregen weil bei wissenschaftler haben
sie das beobachtet oder oder oder jetzt
auch genau auch zum beispiel architekt
lernt die wird das ist sicherlich also
in der charakterbildung das will ich gar
nicht verneinen dass es da bestimmte
elemente natürlich gibt das man sich im
griff haben muss zum beispiel
es kann daher kommen aber es kann
natürlich auch ergebnis seien eines
politischen systems das eben zb die
freie ja die äußerung einer meinung
nicht toleriert dass eben die leute
gerade eine universitäten die
studierenden in china werden nicht in
teil waren aber in china werden hat dann
doch sehr stark kontrolliert
ideologische und ich merke gleichzeitig
auch wenn ich spreche er taub ich mich
schon wieder dabei wie ich wieder in die
vorurteilsfreie die verallgemeinerung
falle tappte in dem ich nämlich so tun
als könnten wir über den chinesen
sprechen
oh ja keiner auf die idee käme über den
europäer zu stören ich will mich ja
wehren wenn ich schon nur einen topf
geworfen wir es mit einer person genau
das ist so lange wir vereinfachen und es
geht sollte darum gehen individuen zu
beobachten zu beschreiben und
individuelle realität zu verstehen ja
vielleicht was mich trotzdem noch
interessiert sie sagen ihnen in ihrem
buch auch wer ostasiatische philosophie
oder ostasiatische gedankenwelten
verinnerlichen will der sollte sich
fernhalten vom geschwätz von der bauer
bespielung von der rund um kommunikation
und in die stille gehen ein stück weit
und gleichzeitig hat ihr buch ja ein
koffer wo man jetzt sagen muss das hat
jetzt mit sich herausnehmen aus dem
gewusel des alltags äußerst wenig musik
muss sich das ironisch verstehen absolut
eine ironische brechung wieder mal also
ich wollte nicht ehrfürchtig das andere
sozusagen da beweihräuchern sondern ich
wollte mich dem anderen aussetzen und
das tue ich ja weiterhin und der
buchtitel bringt das so bisschen ja zum
ausdruck dass eben einerseits dieses wie
sie gerade sagen sagt haben dieses
dieses schweigen als einem zentralen
wert in ostasien gibt und die meditation
habe ich noch nicht viel darüber
gesprochen ist von einem deutschen
philosophen beschrieben worden als ein
hinaus stehen ins nichts
es ist toll gesagt gernot böhme hat das
so gesagt also die idee dass man erstmal
still sein muss und nicht gleich die
eigenen eindrücke die man so macht in
der introspektion gleich wieder
sprachlich erschließen muss dass man
sich einfach geschehen lassen sollte das
ist ein sehr schöner gedanke und den
findet man eben gerade im buddhismus an
zentralen stellen dass das eine aber
daneben sozusagen um zu zeigen dass es
da brüche gibt und widersprüche kommt
dann komme ich dann zurück auf dieses
titelbild das eben da in der tat in der
lebenswelt von chinesen heute so etwas
kaum ja noch platz hat
das heißt die lebenswelt auch jetzt da
wo sie leben leicht mehr diesen
schwimmbad hier
puzzle teil eins ist in deutschland
weniger menschen als in china hat ein
vorteil
in china ist es oft ja in der tat ein
bisschen zu zu zufolge fehlen an vielen
öffentlichen plätzen und der anteil
waren es gibt dadurch rückzugs
rückzugsorte auch in china also zum
beispiel tempel oder bibliotheken und
die menschen es gibt immer menschen die
ein sehr starkes relais gewisses
bedürfnis auch in china die menschen
suchen das natürlich aber es ist eben so
zu sagen dieser kurs scharfe kontrast
dazu der realität reise gemacht durch
chinesische denken eine oberflächen
reise aber wenn sie in den letzten
minuten noch so ein paar ideen
vielleicht noch einmal zusammenfassen
würden was würden sie sagen wer sich auf
chinesische philosophie oder auf
ostasiatische philosophie ein bisschen
breiter gefasst einlassen möchte was
sind die zentralen ideen vielleicht
dennoch die man vielleicht so mitnehmen
können sie oder wo man mal anfangen
könnte darüber nachzudenken
also ich denke ein ganz wichtiges
grundproblem ist die subjektivität
was heißt das eigentlich zu sagen ich
habe jetzt schmerzen über wittgenstein
spielt das eine rolle die sie ist also
wenn man so sätze sagt wie ich habe
schmerzen oder ich fühle wut dann glaubt
man irgendwie mit diesem wort ich auf
etwas bezug nehmen zu können da ist
jemand der spricht und es ist natürlich
dann mit mit dk das problemlos
effektivität ist direkt ins zentrum
gerückt der europäischen philosophie und
in ostasien gibt es gab sehr früh schon
ähnliche überlegungen was heißt das
eigentlich und fast nämlich da
eigentlich bezug wenn ich über mich
selbst spreche im buddhismus und
letztlich hat der buddhismus natürlich
dann die position bezogen das ist dass
ich überhaupt nicht gibt und das kann
man als auch als eine ethik
ausformulieren richtig ich solle mich
nicht um mich sorgen
ich soll nicht die eigene ego
zentralität weiter befördern sondern ich
soll er die ich aus mir heraus treiben
oder soll nicht entledigen und zusagen
öffnen für die realität anderer menschen
und ich denke das ist ein sehr schöner
gedanke und ein sehr wichtiger gedanke
an die von dem man auch sehr viel lernen
kann und also einerseits ich fahre was
ist eigentlich das selbst und das heißt
bewusstsein also wie kann man jenseits
des bewusstseins stroms überhaupt einen
ich annehmen dass da irgendwie sein
transzendentale seco sozusagen
das dann ja kontinuierlich sozusagen die
die einheit meiner erfahrung sichert und
und und und was heißt das für meinen
alltag für meine lebenspraxis das finde
ich weiterhin einen sehr faszinieren
gedanken und dieser gedanke wird bei
vielen buddhistischen denkern
ausbuchstabiert und engagement wäre ein
schöner punkt vielleicht wo man ein
setzen könnte dass man sich national
einmal ist man sich ein text holt und
versucht sozusagen hinein in diesen text
sich hinein zu meditieren oder den auch
rational zu durchdenken
jetzt haben sie zwei varianten sind
hinein meditieren oder rational durch
denke ich denke ich mache beides also
ich denke die philosophie vielleicht bin
ich da von wittgenstein beeinflusst aber
ich denke die philosophie ist natürlich
ein rational hat einen rationalen kern
dass man das man etwas durchdenken
möchte und was man klarheit schaffen
möchte aber es gibt immer auch dieses
therapeutische moment dass man letztlich
in der eigenen lebenswelt gefangen ist
und sozusagen da einfach auch manchmal
die ja sich den erscheinungen und diesem
fluss des lebens strom aussetzen muss um
etwas über sich selbst zu verstehen und
vielleicht gibt es ja sogar weisheit
also dieser diese alters alte
versprechen vieler viele philosophen
neuer weisheit
ich denke dieses versprechen ist noch
nicht tot also wir können da noch mal
also wir sollten darüber nachdenken ob
und wie philosophie und weiser mache ja
genau und die asiaten können uns da
viele ansätze geben oder viele
anregungen geben und anregungen geben
das wäre wahrscheinlich ihre projekte
die wir so in der westlichen philosophie
nicht gefunden haben oder finden
es ist also kein absoluter gegensatz es
gibt überschneidungen natürlich aber es
gibt auch denkt würde ich sagen würde
ich sagen
gerade im buddhismus genuine
überlegungen die man so in europa nicht
nicht ja nicht formuliert hat ja ich
habe etwas gelernt ich glaube wenn man
sich lange mit ostasiatischer wille
sowie auseinandersetzt wird man
vielleicht auch zurückhaltend da im
urteil
das könnte sein dass deskriptive moment
ja dass man vielleicht ja also dass
meine erfahrung erst einmal beschreiben
muss und gerade diese erfahrung der
globalität ist man also ist ein buch
sozusagen das darin an sport in all
seinen sinnen in den anfang genommen hat
also meine erfahrung als ein junger
mensch dass man hinaus geht in die welt
und das da brauchst und rauscht alles da
draußen und irgendwie muss man das
erstmal erfahren verfahren können und zu
sagen vielleicht seinem zweiten schritt
begrifflich durcharbeiten ich möchte
schließen mit konfuzius von dem gibt es
ein zitat der sagte der mensch hat drei
wege klug zu handeln
erstens durch nachdenken das ist der
edelste durch nachahmen das ist der
leichteste durch erfahrung das ist der
bitterste ich bin froh dass wir
nachgedacht haben damit haben wir den
edelsten weg gewählt ob das die tat
schon konfuzius stand oder nicht frage
ich sie jetzt nicht mehr
ich danke ich ihnen sehr kaymer schaut
ja unsere reise nach china setzen jetzt
gleich fort mit einem film der
chinesische kunstschaffende porträtiert
und ihren blick aufs heutige reicht
damit befriedigt nächste woche waren die
sportart und ich einen ausflug ins
delirium in einer sternstunde danach
diskutieren wir mit verschiedenen gesten
worin der reiz des rausches besteht und
ob der wahrhaft glückliche menschen
ebenfalls braucht die sternstunden 8
sehen sie am kommenden samstag um 20 55
auf sf zwei am sonntag dann regulär um
11 ein gespräch mit anne appelbaum über
osteuropa eine gute woche
bis bald
[Musik]